[Music]
s
good evening everybody um some broadcast
information before proceedings commence
if any person present intends to
photograph film or recorded meeting
would they please indicate
now okay that's fine Please be aware
that this meeting will be recorded for
live and for subsequent broadcast on the
council's YouTube channel the whole of
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exemp
sign
this activity promotes Democratic
engagement in accordance with Section
10A of the Local Government Act
1972 all members and officers must use
the microphones provided to enable the
audio to be picked up by systems members
are reminded to turn off their
microphones when they are not formally
addressing the
committee uh so go to our agenda and
number one um attendance is just to ruce
everybody on the top table we've got
senior planning officers and we've got
officers from legal highways and
Democratic Services down both legs of
the table we've got members of
council and and we have apologies this
evening from Council is Stanley the
chair Council cly and councelor
M um there's no other
apologies okay and um I'd like to
welcome our substitute members this
evening councilors Thomas and ad and
Council W I'm the vice chair and I'll be
chairing the meeting this evening
councel with stand his
absence um Declarations of Interest
members to give notice of any personal
or credal interest and the nature of
that interest rela to any item on the
agenda in accordance with the adoped
code of conduct would anybody like to
declare any
interests Council Pro please thank you
chair it's not actually an interest it's
perceived thank
you yes it's G now I wish to address a
perceived conflict of interest around
application 109
337 which is 160 high durston it's the
second time this applications come
before
us and again I wish to address the
challenge of P ity this application is
an owns wward and councelor Kevin proor
will be speaking in support of the
application just as it did last time
when the application came to planning I
want to reiterate we have not discussed
this application together with way many
better things to do with our time away
from Council business than to talk about
individual planning
applications and as such I declared no
interest in this application and will
not be refusing myself from the vote
thank you chair thank you Council
proor thank you thank you chairman um
I'd like to declare a personal interest
in the application at St Ambrose due to
family connection and I can confirm that
I have had paid um no regards the report
uh or being involved in the preparation
of that report I will be roving myself
in the room thank you thank you very
much um okay we go to the next item is
the minutes of the previous meeting on
item three would anybody like to move
those minutes as a true correct thank
you
counil
seconded yesil Hasan um item four on the
agend is questions from members of the
public I understand that no questions
have been submitted from the
public uh number five is the additional
information report there are copies of
that table in front anybody would like
to get a copy the public perhaps and
item six is applications for commission
to develop and the first item we're
going to
discuss first application going discuss
is on page one and that's B Green f b
Lane Bing and there we have an
introduction from Miss
Co thank you chair
um the applications relate to a c listed
brick barn and adjacent modern
agricultural buildings within the
setting of a great T Farmhouse and
within the green belt the applicant
proposes to demolish the modern
agricultural building and the carport
extension and convert the barn into
three dwellings together with hard and
soft Landscaping works there are two
applications under consideration this
evening which we will take together one
for Planning Commission and one for Mr
building consent there will need to be
two separate motions and two votes
members are reminded that an application
to listed Builder consent is to consider
the impact of the development only on
the special architectural historic of
the interest of the building and no
other issues can be considered in
relation to that
application in terms of the application
for planning position the proposed is
considered to be appropriate development
in the green belt falling into the
exception in mpf paragraph 150d which is
the ReUse of buildings of permanent and
substantial construction whilst
preserving the openness of the green
belt there is consequently no need to
consider very special circumstances to
enable the development to proceed in
terms of Heritage impacts for both
application it is considered this as a
result of the alterations to the
buildings the proposed development will
result as some minor harm lesson as
substantial at the lower end of the
scale in mppf terms to the historic and
Architectural interest and the
significance of the Barm and the setting
of The adjacent grade T dist farm house
applying the test in mppf paragraph 202
it is considered that the identified
less than substantial harm would be
outweighed by the public benefits of the
development including bringing the
building back into a viable long-term
use the removal of the modern
utilitarian structures to the fronted
side of the site and the provision of
three additional dwellings which could
be used as family housing proposed Works
will be acceptable with reference to the
listed buildings and conservation areas
at 1990 which requires planning
authorities to have special regard to
the desirability of preserving listed
buildings including any features of
special architectural or historic
interest which it
possesses all other detailed matters
have been assessed in the application of
the Planning Commission including the
proposal housing design visual immunity
residential immunity highway safety and
ecology impacts the local Highway
Authority has no objection the proposal
has been found to be acceptable with
where appropriate specific mitigation
secured by planning condition and The
Proposal complies with development plan
and taken as a poll and policy in the
mppf in relation to these matters in
terms of paragraph 11 D2 which is the
ttic balance it is considered that there
are no adverse impacts that would
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefit granting plan commission
thank
you thank you m coy so um the two
applications are on pages one and 39
we're going to discuss them at the same
time I guess um we've got speaker
against application Mr Dixon Mr
Dixon like to take a seat up the front
and switching microphone on and you have
three
minutes
sorry you have six minutes
you know discussing two applications at
the same time thank
you that's
okay uh good evening thank you for the
opportunity to speak tonight my name is
Bill Dixon I live directly opposite B
Green Farm I have done since 196 1998 at
27 and drive uh and I also represent
the views of various and drive
residents including the Reynolds
McKinnis and Jenkins families who all
live within 50 meters of the farm I'm
not a property or planning professional
I would further add that I'm a trustee
of a Heritage Sports Andy and as such
I'm aware of the inherent responsibility
of land owners to protect sensitive
areas the church Commissioners do not
seem to have any such awareness in this
instance to summarize the situation the
farm and the buildings have been left to
go to stud some years ago the farm is an
asset of the church Commissioners and it
is their responsibility to look after
their assets the solution they are
proposing is to develop the farm out
buildings and solve their problem by
then selling the developments on the
question is whether this is an
acceptable solution given the absence of
real benefits of the community in The
Proposal it is an odd world when a major
share landowner can oversee the
dereliction of a green Bel site and then
suggest that converting the site to
residential is a solution without
mitigating any cost and damage to the
community that is degrading the fact
that the owners believe this needs to be
done is entirely down to decisions that
have made yet we face the consequences
obviously the farm has been on the Green
Belt forever however I fail to see the
need to create three new residential
dwellings on the site there is no
immediate demand for new housing in the
area the site is on a difficult Bend
with several accidents over the years
Bowden Bale is already gridlocked with
traffic at busy times despite reports
residential Planning Commission should
only be granted in my view on green bell
plan in the most exceptional
circumstances if such plan commission is
granted it must
it must meet a higher level of
justification and it must be appropriate
to the protection of the green belts and
benefit the local community the
additional three units have no place in
the green belt are not essential to the
local area nor do they add to amenes the
default position should surely be to
deny position for permission for any
additional residential development in
the green B unless there is an
appropriate compensation to the
community since I have lived in Bowen
Bale the applicant has not been a good
neighbor they have left the farm empty
and deteriorating for number years and
made clear their vision of mass
residential development of the farm they
show no respect for the green Val off
for local community a surprising
position for one of the UK's major
landowners during that time we we
longsuffering neighbors have witnessed
multiple sightings of raps of our
properties increased numbers of foxes
and infestations of flies which appear
to have come from the waste areas of the
farm this is relevant to the application
in so far as it puts on record the
distress cause before this application
was made we consider the Der bar
adjacent tobut to decide to be a danger
it is clearly in disrepair and will
continue to deteriorate which is yes in
any event as an as Bestco survey might
be appropriate on that building as the
application no doubt envisages families
living within a few meters of it in due
course the proposed development itself
is situated on on an already extremely
dangerous Bend and additional traffic
from the three new dwellings will add to
that danger not only is it a dangerous
Bend visibility from the development is
poor I'm quite frankly stunned at the
traffic reports I travel that road daily
with Extreme Caution it is inevitable
that traffic will use the residential
Road of pothole ridden Oakwood Lane to
avoid the developments in its building
pH increasing changes of increasing
chances of accidents for all these
reasons we suggest the application is
submitted is inappropriate and not
worthy of approval however because of
the impact of the applicant actions we
reluctantly accept that something needs
to be done to the buildings given the
incon given the inconvenience the church
commission's negligence is causing and
the Damage that will continue to be
suffered by the neighbors the community
and the green belt the owners might feel
that the creation of three new dwellings
is essential to make the referment
economically viable however the
committee should note that that benefits
the owners only and does not put
anything back to recompense the
distressing inconvenience called so far
and in the future when the development
takes place we have no obligation when
the development takes place we have no
obligation to protect the landowner's
profits what we know is that owners that
the owners have allowed their properties
to deteriorate and see increased
development as the Green Belt as the
only solution this is stand about to
bullying plans seek only to demolish
buildings and infrastructure immediately
adjacent to the proposed plans they do
just enough to probably make the
properties marketable there is other
infrastructure and other buildings that
are not proposed to be removed or
reinstated in these plans and it is
short of the case that these will
continue to deteriorate will the owner
come back in the future and maintain
that the only solution then is further
res residential developments the plans
are submitted are far short of ensuring
that the community is adequately
compensated for the loss of imacy and
addition of three dwellings or that the
land returns to the controlled Healthy
Green Belt that subsisted when the farm
is occupied this application must be
rejected and the church Commissioners
must be urged to resubmit with plans to
remove all agricultural buildings and
infrastructure on the site to reinstate
the site and to improve access to the
site only then will this be considered
an application when The Unwanted
development of three new Residential
Properties might be mitigated with other
improvements within the greenhouse thank
you
sir thank you Mr Dixon if you like to
take his
seat here we have Mr
Smith you have six minutes as well Mr
Smith I hope your microphone is switched
on thank you chair members good evening
um so two applications l in front of you
consideration um has discussed the full
plan application and listed application
the scheme presented is evolved through
proactive uh discussions with officers
resulting in a recommendation of
approval by the cas officer um I didn't
intend to repeat the full committee
reports however I would like to endorse
the case officer's recommendation and
draw attention to the key benefits of
the scheme and the compliance with the
development plan and National plan
policy this for plan application causes
convert the existing cage listed vehic
agricultural building into the three
dwellings as a result of the applican
senstive approach and proed work from
the council there are actually no
objections to the application from any
of the technical
consules whil comments have been
received noing concern from public over
the development of the green belt is
important to highlight the case officer
has confirmed that the proposal is fully
acceptable in terms of greenv policy is
it fals within the exception of the mpf
paragraph 150 Part D which specifically
allows the ReUse of buildings within the
green belt
in this case the removal of the large
modern agricultural building and the car
par part of the proposed development
would result in approximately 400 square
meters reduction of build development
within the green belt which
significantly reduces the existing
negative visual effect and the openness
of the green belt therefore the scheme
not only complies with the requirements
of the mppf it is considered Improvement
of the existing
situation moreover the council's latest
5year housing land Supply position
demonstrates a 3.75 year Supply
at a recent appe in February it was
demonstrated the council may actually
only demonstrate between 2.82 and 3.47
year Supply which is below the fiveyear
supply
requirement paragraph 11d of the npf
states that a presumption in favor of
sustainable development applies if the
council are unable to deliver a fiveyear
housing man Supply the proposed for
three dwellings will deliver a sensitive
and high quality scheme to support the
delivery of housing in an area where it
is in fact new the most and it also
makes the most effective use of land in
accordance with the mppf paragraph 119
by utilizing an existing building which
would otherwise live a and is Exemplar
alter to building on green t
sites as a result of the above the
proposal is acceptable in principle and
there are no technical objections to the
scheme turning to the list of building
content application this was submitted
in January 2022 and un like the full
plan application it has undergone
thorough assessments over the past year
and a half the Conover and the F offer
have concluded that the works will be
acceptable and welcomed and would
welcome the ReUse of this vacant and
deterior build with reference to section
16 of the planning list of building and
cons conservation
arey the building been V for a number of
years and is no longer required for
agricultural purposes due to the
advancement of agricultural practices
the building is not no longer suitable
size to be used by modern agricultural
vehicles and equipment and as such is in
need of a long-term use to ensure the
building do not fall into a further
state of disrepair the scheme will see
the curist and brought back into an
optimal viable use which is supported by
local and National planning policy the
applicant's worth gra be with the
conservation officer and the planning
officer to deliver a high quality scheme
which is sympathetic to the character
and appearance of the adjacent gr listed
Farmhouse the scheme has been designed
to protect as much of the existing
fabric of the Doan as possible with sens
sensitive material selection for the
works and the use of reversal internal
50 things so that historic interest can
be
rained the conservation officer and the
cas officer have agreed that the post
development will result in less than
substantial harm which is at the lower
end of the impact scale and applying the
test set out in the mpf the council have
concluded that they identifi less than
substantial harm will be out by the
public benefits mentioned earlier it is
noted that the council and planning
committee have recently approved similar
applications this year for conversion of
agricultural buildings and the green BS
and curtil listed agricultural buildings
into residential use it is therefore a
well established principle that this
form development is acceptable and we
would have welcom the council approach
to be consistent with previous decisions
to summarize there are no objections to
I applications from any professional
consulties including local Highway
Authority flood Authority conservation
officer ecologist agriculturalist
archaeologist and environmental health
offices as such the proposal fully proc
calls with the development plan National
planning policies which establishes a
presumption in favor of sustainable
development we therefore request that
you support the offic recommendation and
Grant commission thank you Mr Smith like
to to
your just somebody mentioned Mr Dixon
mentioned
ASP I would discuss that issue at all on
this
application um no chair but it's not a
matter for the for the planning
committee it's a matter for the health
and safety executive and if um asbestos
is not Disturbed um then then it is it
generally considered same to remain but
if it was to be uh Disturbed then a
licensed contractor would be required
but it's other under different
legislation to the process I think um
I'm looking for reassurance that that
issue will be will be examined it's not
being Sol by now that it will be it's
not something we're
ignoring um I'm I'm advised by um col to
the construction management as
well happy with that thank you Miss ker
um as I say the applications are on page
one and 30 now we'll discuss them at the
same time um I'll invite members to
comment anybody wishing to speak Council
proor thank you chair it's actually a
question and a
disappointment I like this plan my
auntie in West Cumbria did something
very very similar with the milking
parlor and adjacent bars at her
Farmhouse but she had level entrance to
every single
home this doesn't this it's a stepped
entrance and it's a lost opportunity to
create a more accessible home for
somebody and I wonder my question is has
anybody in the planning team challenged
the um developer to make level access
thank
you um as I understand it as the we have
balanced here the requirement to
minimize part historic fabric which is a
uh Duty which really need to get very
significant weight to um against
accessibility and one one of the
accesses is level um and the others
aren't but they would all comply with M
for one given given the build is
building just its status um so we think
that appropriate balance has has been
reached it is a general principle in in
list building with bar conversions that
you minimize um increasing the size of
openings wherever you can and where a
thre and and a historic threshold is is
generally a raised threshold as well um
so that was the exercise that was
carried out obviously members can come
to a different view they they want
to it's a lost opportunity and it's a
disappointment in what looks to
be something really simple overlooked in
ins sign that could be very easily
worked around without damaging a stone
threshold just by the inclusion
of a very slight incline into each of
the other homes thank you thank you
Council pro councel
thomask thank you chair you just to vot
on what counc Pro said is B
715 um says that all should be fully
accessible and it's backed up in the
mppf paragraph 167 and where they
reaches M for the building uh
regulations but it doesn't re uh things
and the introduction of ramps could be a
condition that waniz the fabric of a
other building and i' like it as a a
condition if it's workable also no
disable or sorry accessible parking now
on the uh on the plans the parking
spaces seem reasonably uh spacious but
again it's it's something that people
with accessibility issues do need
slightly more space and again it's
something that I think we should be
looking to enforce when when we can as
it's part of our our policy
other than that I'm very impressed with
the the building in the site it's not
something I can vote against on but I
think it's something that as a a
committee with the strategy that we
should point out and ask developers to
include as it's not an overly expensive
uh remed to our
policy thank you if I could just come
back on the accessible parking these are
private dwellings and with with
effectively with parking spaces outside
their front door uh we would treat them
like we would treat any other houses
parking spaces out the front door we
would not require dedicated accessible
parking there's no policy that that
requires that so um it if we did that we
would need to ask everybody building a
pair of semis to provide accessible
parking and that would be
unreasonable again chair I appreciate
that and that wasn't part of the
condition condition that's just a
request perhaps we don't know if we
don't ask if we ask the developers
developers I don't not talk about now
developers may be quite happy to go L
with us and and have provision in there
there's one parking space that you can
sit on there that is it could be deemed
accessible uh and the other parking
spaces could be wide enough to not
require that and appreciate priv land
but it's a request just to make sure
that
wey thank you coun
counc
thank you
chair it's a difficult one for me
um whil you know I have every sympy with
the residents you know on the street and
the potential
problems uh they can see in future but
I'm trying to understand that what else
could be done with the you know property
itself because it's not easy to sort of
maintain you know a property of that
scale and uh
in my experience once somebody leaves a
farm it's very hard for another farmer
to come and take it you know and running
as a farm it's very hard these days and
you know I I share the same sentiment uh
with my colleague that it's a lost
opportunity could have been different
like a private one sort of big huge ding
with minimal increas in the traffic and
you the number of residents using the
services um but overall when I looked at
the management plans I think it covers
all the points um you know that how this
Prof development should proceed and all
the points you know in the framework
they been addressed and all the
stakeholders so I think I'll be happy to
propose that we approve this thank you
thank you for that Council Council
Jerome thanks chair um I also feel like
a council barar as well I was a little
bit torn when I first saw this
application and obviously an application
that's on the Green Belt which should
always take
seriously um but I think we we did hear
a number of things which I thought were
important it does reduce the building
footprint on the land actually with the
barn going so that that there will be
less building actually on on on the
green Bel after this application is you
know it's approved and finished um it
will bring vacant buildings um back into
use um which no longer have a need for
agricultural use and I I did look at the
objections and I do have a lot of
Sympathy for the residents um the
highway um problems are real you know
speeding cars on that road are
treacherous are cycle down many a time
and I've seen much of the congestion
problems but I don't think we can lay
that on the applicants St um it's not
really their responsibility to solve the
highways issues in in my opinion um but
also um the problem the rats mentioned
hopefully with buildings on there you
know that the problem of WRA might be
alleviated to to some degree um but also
in the officer report of paragraph 18 it
does say that um it will stop any future
limited development rights so any
changes to the buildings in the future
would have to come back to this
committee um for us to look out to see
if they do kind of impinge upon the
green belt you know any any further
so I was a little bit tall on this
application but I think I'd also second
the proposal to support offic
recommendation thank you chair thank you
councel
coun thank you I'm fully agreed with my
previous speakers my councel my
colleague have said but I'm really very
impressed with the uh Mr Smith yes uh I
think he very precisely and very
comprehensively and technically he has
said everything in few words and
objections coming through through the no
technical objection has come and
Greenland is f is not affecting anything
and also it is improving the existing
building and it means high quality
building coming through and uh and and
it is a a beautiful compatibility
between the local and National land so
in brief I would say I fully recommend
this appication and that's it thank you
thank you C anybody else wishes to
comment um Council proor talked about uh
making all the Living Spaces level the
entry one is level uh we can't insist on
that I think she was testing the water
to see the support of the meeting does
anybody want a second Council proce
proposal that we insist or if we can do
look to our legal advisor if we can
assist all the entrances be be leveled
Thomas second that um so need to proceed
with the vote so on the the first uh
item is is around um the use of the
site found to be converted I think we
can safely vote on that without talking
about the Le prevention am I right
thinking
that perhaps ask the committee if
anybody objects to that condition being
imposed does anybody object to the
condition that Council Thomas and counc
these objects Council
TA in which case take a vote so we you
take a vote on whether we'll accept uh
the proposal from Council proor yeah all
those in favor Council Proctor's
proposal that we make the properties all
level for disabled access everybody
understanding that seeing blank faces
everybody understanding that you
understanding that
okay what council proor suggesting is
that level accesses are provided to the
two accesses that aren't level at the
moment that could be done in one of
could be done in a number of ways but
the most likely way would either to be
to take them with the building material
out under the door and put in a bigger
door so that they access is the then
level and then it ramps up inside the
house if there needs to be a change of
level or ramp an external ramp is put up
to the um up to the access obviously
that would lead rails and so on and
would have um a visual impact on on the
on the listed building it is my advice
that the um the harm to the listed
building would um in this case outweigh
the accessibility particularly given the
weight that the two things are given in
natural policy and in respect to the
regard that must be taken
but members are entitled to give
whatever weight that they feel um and
can proceed
accordingly thank you m get some legal
advice we're not going to get legal
advice the chair she set out position
perfectly we
can the committee can then consider the
uh the resolution
proposal first second yeah okay the only
thing is I would say I think
Precision this is this is the issue it's
not just simple a matter of sorry of the
level the access it's the way that in
fact it's to be it's to be done because
as the chair as the chief planning
officers made clear there are various
Solutions I think we need to have a
clear view as to what is proposed you've
heard the uh Chief planning officer set
out various Alternatives I think we need
some clarity from the proposers as to
what they actually putting before the
commit Council Pro would you like to
make it clear what's being put forward
to the members
sure and start off I'd like to ask the
developer now will you make level access
just yes or no I'm a bit worried about
getting into discussion
not we're not I'm a bit makes me
cautious counsel
Pro um do you want to
continue yeah okay thank
you I would not want to disturb the
fabric of the building
because like for example my auntie's
nugin parlor had Arrow slits for Windows
didn't wi them they had tiny little
window panes put in and building looked
amazing this is a matter of exous it's
not three steps or four steps into
either of the other two houses it's a
step and that would be so easy to remedy
just
by the laying of whatever pathway went
into that part of the
building I don't think it necessarily
would involve um ramps with g handrails
because it's not a flight stairs it's
one it's a
threshold but then you have an
engineering operation which isn't part
of the
application it it I don't think it is
quite as easy in this particular case as
it might be in another
because of the also because of the
application to building consent as well
which is works as opposed to development
so there's a there's a there's a greater
impact there and a greater level of
granularity that you have to go into if
if you look at the number of conditions
that are on both the applications you'll
see quite how many there are and that is
because of that need for that
granularity and understanding absolutely
exactly what is what's happening and if
you start talk about raising ground
levels that could have all sorts of
knock on impacts and I have to say where
I've seen them ramp up with the ground
levels and we went to one of these on
the outcomes talk is it it's much it's a
much bigger operation than than than you
think and it and it doesn't always have
a a great
outcome um I think if this wasn't if
this was a wasn't a listed building I
think I'd be a lot more comfortable but
it is and we have to start on that basis
and we also have to start on the basis
that that the Heritage harm carries has
to carry very great weight and and that
that is the that is the primary
consideration in this application and in
fact the only consideration of the list
of building nothing else is is um is is
up for grabs on that
one coun Thom want to come in yeah just
just for what sh says again there's no
harm and there's no damage to listed
buildings to have a payment that rises
and Falls by six in over a
long uh along the run so it's not it's
not steep but that does in effect just
by Rising 6 Ines does in effect allow
wheelchair users to travel toight go
straight in without having to take any
brick work away it's just a matter of
raising slightly the levels towards each
door or the two that aren't level access
it's not it's not a great it's not going
to be a hill it's not like having a
levice outside your front door it's
having a side ra graving it over a long
period that means that a is not steep B
it's highly liking it to be unnoticeable
doesn't need
handrails just it just seem watchable to
me I'm
afraid I don't think we can know any of
that councilor Thomas I think that's the
problem we can't know that it won't need
to be steep we can't we don't know what
the the levels are on site to make that
judgment we don't know that it won't
need handrails we we we can't I don't
think we can we can with any confidence
to say that those things aren't correct
and if we can't say that
then the the decision is challengeable
if we try and make those um
claims okay
just just to be another side to to the
story here I think it's um completely
unreasonable to request that the
developer do what um colleagues in the
room are requesting them to do at the
end of the day if somebody requires
access to their home they tend to have
accessibility features installed
temporarily they need it it doesn't need
to be an intrinsic part of the property
and the
development um I completely understand
where the colleagues are coming from um
but priority is preserving the Heritage
I don't think it's reasonable all to
almost Force the developer to to push
through these um what what can sound my
simple changes but would be huge changes
to the for the property and I can
appreciate what find enough to saying
about that so I just want to give an
opposing comment on that from from the
table thank you thank you councel is L
so we're going to vote on Council proor
and councel Thomas's second proposal
that we ask for the all the accesses to
the properties to be level access in the
sense of disability access you've heard
the arguments for so this is not this is
just to decide whether we take that uh
Amendment for and add it to our
conditions Council Min you want to make
a
comment I think that without the clarity
of exactly what we're asking and how
it's to be done um I think given that
you can't we're not we're not saying
this is exactly how it's to be done to
may keep the Heritage aspect um I don't
think it's something you can um do
because we don't have a clear way um
it's different it's a real shame because
obviously if we can make something
accessible we should do absolutely but I
think that if you can't we haven't got a
clear way of doing it and we don't know
there's a lot of unknowns you can't put
stipulate something to be done without
knowing how so um just urging of to
think about that rather than you know
the thing we'd love to
have
okay we'll go to a vote on that on
Council Pro's proposal all those in
favor of council proxus proposal adding
a condition please
show and those against that
proposal okay hands down so that
proposal has been
lost um I think uh Council Barber
proposed that we accept the application
on page one and Council Jerome seconded
it yeah
we'll vote on that so the change of use
of an existing traditional agricultural
building to create three residential
units can members can members not speak
please to change the use of exting
traditional agricultural build to create
three residential unit the principle of
the development what we're voting on now
all those in favor the principle of
development that we vote of the
development of this s Poli
show down I think that's unanimous
just just clarify chair that was voting
for The planning
application yeah on page 39 uh list of
building consent for change of use of
existing traditional agult or buildings
to create three residential units with
Associated external
alterations Associated car parking and
imunity space if you like the fabric of
the new buildings the big issue with
Council Thomas and Council Pro to all
those in favor everybody understand what
I just said yeah all those in favor of
granting that application please
sure hands down those
against thank you that's been carried so
the application both applications have
been approved thanks everybody for your
contributions and well now now go to 160
higher Road that's on page 56 of your um
application packs and M K is going to
give us an introduction to this one
M thank you chair um this application
relates to the development of lands
currently occupied by a single story
vacant industrial Warehouse the
immediate surrounding area is
predominant residential comprising of
two story semi- detached and Terrace
dwellings the application proposes the
erection of five three story terrorist
WS members will recall that this
application was originally brought to
the Planning Development management
Committee in June 2023 it was deferred
and the applicant has made positive
changes to the scheme which mean it can
now be recommended for approval the
application has receiv received letters
of objection from four neighboring
addresses and one Anonymous
representation the main concerns relate
to overlooking and loss of privacy
security scale of the development noise
disturbance and Odus from vins the
proposed rings fall slightly short of
adopted guidelines in relation to
distances to rear boundaries and window
to window distances although unbalance
and given the prevailing character of
the area the separation distances are
considered to be acceptable in terms of
visual immunity The Proposal does not
fully reflect the context of the site
and its surroundings in terms of design
and materiality nevertheless it
represents an inovative contemporary
approach incorporating Energy Efficiency
measures and is considered overall to
constitute the appropriate design respon
of the site and the council does not
currently have an immediately available
5e supply of housing land tilted balance
would apply the proposal would create
five new family dwellings in a
sustainable Brownfield location and
would therefore make a modest
contribution to L's housing Supply
development also generate a small amount
of economic benefit during construction
work in addition it's recognized that
development will provide environmental
benefits through the provision of energy
efficient homes and social benefit
through the provision of accessible and
adaptable homes in stainable location in
weighing the planning balance it's
considered that the identified CS would
not significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits of the proposed
scheme The Proposal complies with the
development plan as a whole and is
recommended for approval thank
you thank you Mr Co do we have Mr Honus
Mr
Honus like to take a seat switch your
microphone on you have three
minutes thanks everyone uh good evening
my name is John hus my wife Emma thanks
for inviting us along tonight just to
clarify myself and Emma live in the
house directly south of the site so our
garden is just the other side of the
plan properties we have several serious
concerns but I just like to stress that
we're not objecting out of principle
we're being as constructive as possible
and we're suggesting solutions to our
concerns we'd like to see changes made
to the plant um addition all of our
points are supported by our nextal
neighbor at number
25 um first point is about security so
the fence between our garden and the
proposed properties is low in fact even
a child will be able to climb over it
this fence is now inadequate and it
should be made part of the plans to
increase the height for the security of
all parties uh this is actually a point
raised by gr Manchester police as well
the second one is about privacy and
overlooking So currently the only
privacy screen in place is a row of
trees which are on our land without
these trees our house would be left
completely overlooked by the new houses
we appreciate the revised plan to plant
a new row of trees on the new properties
however anyone who knows about gardening
will know that it will be impossible for
these to grow due to the established
root system of the existing trees a
solution would be to plant these new
trees closer to the new houses uh we
want reassurance that our trees aren't
threatened to be cut down by order of a
high hedge notice because these are
currently the only things in the plan
that provide privacy between the
properties and it is the responsibility
of ourselves and our neighbors at number
25 to maintain this privacy screen which
doesn't seem
fair third point is about bins uh
currently they're too close to our
property in the plan we're concerned
about bad odors and poor hygiene also
due to the hidden nature of the alleyway
area the residents are highly likely to
use this for bins and waste storage the
best solution we clearly be to move the
bin storage to discrete sheds at the
front of the planned
houses fourth point is about over
development so the separation distance
is significantly lower than the 13 M
guideline and significantly lower than
the average for the area which proves
that these new properties are in
overdevelopment if approved it would set
a dangerous precedent which may cause
this planning committee problems for
future applications in
traffic fifth point is about height and
scale the new properties is
significantly higher than the
neighboring properties which is out of
scale for the area and six point about
noise so we live in a quite C we're
concerned about the noise from the
additional five families the plan is
inadequate in terms of any soundproof
into consideration and this is an
example of overcrowded potential
solution to this would be of course to
build fewer properties instead of five
uh finally please can you update
proposal brochure with the new roof
design because currently there are seven
pages with illustrations that are
incorrect and misleading page numbers
are in our written statement um it's
very important there's no confusion in
future about what would be built here
thanks for your time
thank you very much Mr thank you very
much Mr H like to return to your seat
councilor proor you're going to speak in
favor of the
application you want to go first or
yeah thank you chair um I spoke about
the last committee meeting to give my
support to the scheme I'd like to do so
again tonight
as I said previously I think it's an
exciting proposal which is raising the
bar in terms of construction design and
meets the need to provide good family
housing in the in
area the development meets most of the
council's wider objectives providing
good quality five units of family
recommendation on a ground field site
with the added bonus of Energy
Efficiency features to help with the
cost of living for all those families we
also a bik store to encourage
cycling in addition we generate a small
amount of economic activity in the area
connected with the construction process
the homes will also be designed to m42
standard which sets the highest standard
for accessible homes which is broadly
equivalent to the lifetime home
standard this application has been in
processed for a long time now and during
the whole period appli have been working
hard to meet the objection objections of
the P team is my view view that they
have done that and demonstr a high
flexibility and willingness to
compromise and to meet issues raised by
officers concerning the PLS at the
previous meeting the application was
approved contrary to Officer's
recommendation and deferred and
delegated the imposition conditions to
the head of planning it was however
found not to be possible to impose those
lawful planning conditions in line with
committee's original
wishes not withstanding this since the
committee meeting in June applicant was
chosen to amend scheme as engaged with
officers to address some of the concern
rais planning team which should believe
this now Alters the planning bars as
such as the pr is now able to recommend
the approval I very much support this
View and hope that members can also that
tonight the main positive aspects of the
new plans are well detailed in the
report so I won't go through th those
however I just like to mention the
Overlook aspect of the scheme which was
particularly picked up in the last
meeting um overall I would like to
support the scheme and um i' like to say
that uh I hope that the committee prove
that tonight uh in line with other
recommendations and application thank
you chair thank you Council Pro mxon you
want to
comment if it's at all possible Miss
Dion could you address some of the
concerns raised by the neighbor if it's
possible that's
yeah um so uh thank you committee um
members
[Music]
and yes so thank you for your time to
it's appreciated um and just thank you
for bearing with me also I cre my way
through this um my name is Hannah Dixon
and I'm an architect and pass house
designer um and the director of progress
and practice uh small architecture
practice based Inon um and it's my
personal ambition um to bring passive
house and N Zero Energy building to uh
Trafford um I Met George and Catherine
for the first time on a rainy afternoon
in the warehouse on High Road in
20120 um it was lockdown so it's
socially distanced uh but we discussed
creating a as beautiful and sustainable
scheme as we possibly could um on the
15th of June this year after a long
journey we brought uh the scheme to
committee and it was passed by members
but
unfortunately um we were asked res
committee is there was some confusion
about some of the planning conditions
that were asked to be imposed um and to
be clear we weren't asked or obliged to
change the scheme in any way however
during the previous committee meeting uh
points were raised by local resident um
who would not met because they weren't
able to make the the community
consultation that we had on site um and
in response to this feedback and some of
the discussions months members previous
committee meeting would made quite uh
significant changes to the planning
application in collaboration with
planning
department um so the changes proposed to
improve the scheme of significant and
are as
follows um we've included fob access to
the rear gin Gardens as a shared Garden
to the RO
properties we've enhanced the screening
by adding R birch trees to the border to
the boundary um there's no there's no
plan to just the removal of the
screening to the properties to the rear
um we've handed the entire second floor
so that all of the second floor bedrooms
face to the front of the properties so
there is we have completely eliminated
the overlooking concerns to the rear or
the risk of overlooking to the rear of
properties on second
floor um we've emitted all together the
dormers on the second floor so we've
taken away the Dormers and gone instead
for a an asymmetrical roof Arrangement
which was sponsored by a consultation
with the planning department
directly um and it's it's reflective of
some of the asymmetrical roofs that
exist in Inon
already um and given the support that
the committee expressed at the last
meeting to the uh the m42 standards um
we thought it was important to reflect
the how the plans would work within this
context so we've added annotation to
time
already s so much effort has been put
into reaching compromise on this uh
scheme and balancing the needs of all
future um of all parties including the
planning department local residents and
future residents and I feel that I can
confidently say that the current scheme
works hard to be sensitive and
considerate was delivering maximum
benefit from a Brandford site um and the
proposals are for
uh five highly
sustainable family homes which can move
far forward in terms of low energy
building in traff thank you m di if to
turn to your seat thank you thank
you okay we open up the debate any
members wishing to speak Council
next well I think that this is much much
more improved from um the previous um
proposal one part I can't quite get over
it's this it's the height and of of the
building and it
being so the neighboring buildings
obviously the same he as each other will
um and and it does it does sit
differently which um I just feel it
doesn't quite fit in that way um
um I
guess it's I feel like it's a bit too
much on the pot um more I'm more than
happy with like the like bu building on
Brownfield site but I feel like if we
had four houses that were a bit shorter
therefore you get the same amount of
living space but um but not as high up
um that would I think would sit better
on the on the road um so I I don't think
at the minute I'm on the leaning on the
not supporting side because I feel like
it's a bit too much on the
bo know whatever else think we see thank
you councelor Min councel
D thanks chair um I was supported of
this scheme last time I think it's it's
a great scheme and sensible location um
I'd like apply applicant for the way
which they've gone about you know
responding to concerns from fing offes
on on residents
um like said I'll be supporting it again
to you councel Deacon anybody else
councel
Aon yeah same as my
colleague councelor he um I I actually
think this is a really good scheme and I
think it will enhance the whole world
of um has has been a
blind before and I don't think you can
you'll get anything
we go back again so I I fully support it
and I move
that can and counc
Thomas thank you CH
I'm a little bit
um contr to what's been said purely on
the fact that there one parking space
per four bedroom house which although we
have a maximum of5 bedroom is well below
that I'm very concerned that the
pavement will be removed to the front of
the hous on high road anybody with two
cars in that family or potentially three
parking around there is disastrous the
best of times certainly evening um which
creates a problem Ming I do think as
Council Min said that four houses in the
space available would perhaps have
been
more amable to to myself to my thoughts
uh and the high again the height is very
overbearing to the the properties to the
right and left however in saying that
they're not things I don't think I can
vote against it for but I do think that
things like the parking and the uh
access to the parking spaces and what's
going to be done regarding the pavement
on higher Road has to come into play and
what we
decide you coun counc
jome thanks
CH I think this is a an excellent
application I do have sympathy for
Council Minister's position councel
Thomas I think it does note in in the
report near the end that the design um
is slightly out of keeping with the
street scene but on balance I think you
know that can be accepted um and also
again on this application I think it's
paragraph 95 they hav't removed Comm
development rights so any extensions
that wanted to be done
come this committee so that that might
limit any future kind of extension to
what is high high buildings so that kind
of makes me a lot happier but having
five buildings to passive our standards
is absolutely amazing and and those
types of buildings can be so energy
efficient that they can reduce energy
bills to less than 100 pounds a year so
you know to create that kind of standard
of of home with that kind of energy
efficiency for for our residents I think
it's massively good
so I'm supporting this application
thanks Jeff thank you councel J
coun completely agree with what Dan said
last time round I like this I liked it
because it's to Lifetime home
standards and passive houses in Herston
and I accept they are a bit higher than
the houses either side but they're no
higher than the houses
opposite so when you look at haer Road
in General rather than just looking at
these five houses and the ones either
side it is in keeping with the street
it's high Road's got all sorts of
different housing stuff on it the bottom
end where this is on the as you're
looking towards MOS Bale road all the
houses on the left are big Victorian
teres compared
to on on the screen the house the two
two houses to the right are small
Cottages I love it and I'll be voting in
favor as well Council proor anybody else
has anybody moved and seconded the
application going move
it second just remind
me for my
benefit
wasn't a council motion wasn't Council
Minister wasn't in favor she was
listening to the debate thing that's
what
she um so has been moved and seconded
all those in favor this application
please
show and those
against that's unanimous thank you
everybody that's application has been
approved
we can now go to St Ambrose and that is
on page 99 of your
application before we begin our speakers
M n's going to give us an introduction m
nmer
thank you chair so this application
relates to um St Ambrose College on hail
Road specifically to two multi-use Gain
areas um muggers and these are
artificial pictures within the grounds
of the college and the application seeks
to vary condition 24 of the Planning
Commission
74747 from 2010 which related to the um
construction of the college as a whole
um the condition 24 for at the time when
it was granted um related to the hours
of use of the muger pitches um with the
main pitch having flood lights um the
application proposes to extend the hours
of use by one hour um on Mondays and
Fridays excluding bank holidays and
public holidays um so it would see Sho
at 8:00 pm rather than the current 7
p.m. objections have been received from
15 different neighboring uh residents
and Council of birth has also objected
includ in the application in support of
the local residents objections concerns
um from the judges relate to the impact
on amenity through noise and disturbance
from the um increasing use of the um the
artificial pictures um and the flood
lights there is also concern about
the colleges um willingness to abide by
those conditions and the enforceability
of those conditions um however the the
application has been reviewed by the
council's Environmental Protection
Service and a noise assessment was
submitted um and they have found that
they they have no objection to the
increase erors of use similarly um
objections related to parking on site
and the applicant submitted a transport
assessment which has been reviewed by
the local harer Authority and again they
raised no
objection um furthermore the school of
the applicant have worked with the
planning department to agree conditions
to provide a greater level of control
and Assurance about the management of
the pitches with conditioned to within
the application report and updated
within your additional information
report setting out that management plan
which does include um the adding of
screens to the flood lights closest to
the Residential Properties on the carus
um therefore subject to those conditions
um we do not consider there to be a
harmful impact on residential amenity or
highway safety whilst the concerns of
residents are knowledge is considered
those conditions can um overcome
mitigate the impact and we do have um
now in place an enforcement team that
can review any breaches of condition
therefore subject to the conditions
we're going to report an additional
information report we do recommend
approval thank you chair thank you Mr n
um it's a little bit dark down here I
don't know the lights go
up a screen okay um no speakers in favor
of the application we've got a statement
against the applications M Lo going read
that thank you m
l thank you chair this is a statement
from um two neighboring residents and
that will um take the three minutes
firstly and David David suer from wian
the school made no efforts to meet the
neighbors and built no confidence that
they have any concern for our well-being
we know the previous conditions were
blatantly flouted and it's on record
that the council were informed of this
the council claimed to be unaware sorry
the school claim to be unaware of any
conditions this gives little confidence
that any new conditions will be adhered
to and nowhere is there any reference to
any penalty for non-compliance what make
what might make it more likely that they
would adhere to any conition
unfortunately I away in holiday when the
committee meets to discuss can I ask
that this letter is read out with a
request that any approve approval is
postponed until we see what the noise
management plan is how it will be
monitored and what penalties for
non-compliance would be the school has a
bad track record on this and it's only
reasonable that any approval not only
sets conditions but makes them
realistically enforceable finally this
is the latest in a series of
applications to try and extend the hours
of use of the fields if you're going to
approve can we have a condition that no
further application is made to extend
our hours of use for a minimum of 13
years being the time since the original
application was approved and ideally 20
years by which time most neighbors will
no longer be
affected and John kid 10 ashme this
application is is to allow St Ambrose to
extend the hours Allowed by the college
to the college by the planning
department and the council for the use
of the
pictures and therefore increase the
levels and volume of lighting parking
traffic and noise well beyond these
hours
residents located both north and south
of the school grounds have had to suffer
from this deterioration of amenities to
the heavily increasing extent over the
past few years since approval was
granted about 10 years ago for the
creation of the college some conditions
set by the planning department and
approved by the council have been
ignored apparently contravening policies
within the Trafford revised unitary
development plan the council re relies
on the planning department to set
conditions when approval is granted and
a comprehensive set of conditions was
created Ed but no action has been taken
when the college has severely breached
several conditions generating noise
parking traffic and traffic issues
condition 14 areas for parking shall be
made available at all times adjacent
streets are being used by school pupils
and our traffic Anor traffic Hazard
recognized by the introduction of yellow
parking restriction lines condition 12
deliveries and collection times access
to Refuge collection area is
uncontrolled and causes noise andat as
ear as 5:30 a.m. condition 19 a
community use scheme shall be submitted
to and approved in writing by the local
planning Authority no such plan has ever
been pres presented or authorized the
current application requests an
extension of condition 24 and the hours
of recreational use is clearly a formal
request to authorize further breaches of
conditions affecting and impacting the
quality of neighboring
amenities thank you Miss Los um
Council Evans like to take a seat and
you have five minutes counc thank you
chair nice to see you back in the
chair um it's very it's difficult to
expand on what those two residents have
actually said but thank you chair for
the opportunity to
speak start again thank you chair for
the opportunity to speak on behalf of
the residents on the surrounding roads
that will be adversely affected if this
permission is granted tonight apologies
from my colleague councelor but who
originally called this in following
numerous calls and emails from residents
I've also been in contact with the
previous Council Moran and Myers who
both also report continuous stream of
complaints around the lights and
unauthorized use of these
pictures as we approach Autumn and the
clocks go back in hour what is a small
problem today is magnified as the trees
lose their leaves and nights draw in the
original permission was for skill use
only to 700 p.m. was which was extended
at some point to rental and now our
residents are being asked to tolerate
further extension to 8:00 p.m. to
highlight the problems of one of our
resident who Fosters children and puts
them to bed at 7:00 p.m. each night they
are blighted by unacceptable light
pollution and noise now read what they
say 26 of June
23 um please can I inform you we are
disappointed your Oh wrong wrong one
sorry um it's now 8:25 and we've been
pushing our children to bed
unfortunately complaining at this second
evening the lights are being left on
second of October unfortunately the
lights have been left on again and
that's before the clocks go back 5th of
October lights still on at 4:07
a.m. these residents as he's touched
upon in additional information has
suffered the effects of these lights
since they were installed when the new
school was built to replace the old
building I've been pass numerous photos
from all hours as I already highlighted
400 a.m. in the morning isn't uncommon
where the end of Resident Gardens look
like Black Balloon ations if this is
granted it will be 8:00 p.m. every night
for at least 9 months of the year
virtually impossible to put toddler to
bed had the school acted in a reasonable
manner for the past few years our
residents may have been were more
sympathetic I'm sure we will be assured
of a sound management plan for these
lights but given the management of the
current lights has consistently failed
and specifically as I've highlighted in
the weeks approaching this meeting
hardly shown concern for our residents
but a desktop ser survey and assurances
to planning officers and clearly the
environmental report that's been
referred to doesn't fairly represent the
reality on the ground for our residents
the Assurance of enforcement is clearly
failed today and clearly despite
officers assurances they are likely to
fail again presume most members here
have attempted to get enforcement at
some point without success not just on
light but on anything our residents
obviously have no confidence in the
school to introduce a management plan as
the current one fail since Inception and
when the management plan fails there is
no mechanism for redress being B they
have been badly let down by the school's
failure to communicate failure to
meaningfully consult and failure to
manage their current permissions one
could argue that current permission
should be rescinded through failure to
to ad to conditions if this is granted
tonight this will only be exacerbated I
would ask the commit committee on behalf
of the residents to refuse this
application as the impact on residents
enjoy their properties and lives will be
seriously impacted and this can't
possibly be outweighed by any perceived
benefit so thanks for your time tonight
appreciate the ability to speak thank
you thank you counc to return
to thank you chair yes I am aware of
that particular resident and councelor
Evans um mentions and I did visit um
that Resident site to look at it from
from their side um what we and I think I
also note the comments about the the
conditions but what I would say is that
since
2010 the planning enforcement team has
come back into the the planning
department um and is very proactively
managed um so when we get complaints now
we will look into it in regards to the
lights being on at 400 a.m. the school
fully acknowledged is that they have
they are having problems with
malfunctioning lights and they said that
is a particular problem they're dealing
with at the moment what they've also
agreed to do um is install addition
additional lighting screens kind of
lighting CS around the flood lights
adjacent to various residential Gardens
so if I move on to this one so you've
got flood lights kind of
along so you can't see my C
um flood lights along the sides here and
the lights at the subn end closest to
the the back of these Residential
Properties will have um lighting screens
installed to prevent lights spill and
and that is within the management plan
so we've agreed that we'll have
specification details and time scales
for installation to be um
submitted thank you m n councilor Thomas
make a comment thank
you
thank you chair fully in favor of this
plan I think it's a great idea even
without the couples that we mentioned
ear improves it nonetheless excuse me
nonetheless it could be perhaps a
condition that school keeps a log of
when the lights go arai U with the plan
officers and enforcement from look at
but it opens up um Sports Health
Community Access which is much needed I
think it's extremely
uh in view of the local community the
only goes to 8:00 there are many schools
around Trafford I go to 10:00 with lines
for to utilize pites are there propose
that we accept this with I think is
no thank you councelor
minis I've got a slightly different view
um I think that really I have great deal
of Sympathy for the residents that live
nearby and the idea of of having
something having
the lights Etc going on till
10:00 fill them with red no no I know I
know this is 8:00 you talking about
school um so I mean I think that given
how close it is I'm afraid to um the
pitches are to to residential houses I
don't think it's fair um to subject them
to it to to the lights and noise and
everything that goes with it to elator I
think that um you know I think it's
point to people getting their kids to
bed in turn time especially on the
holidays and um not having the noise and
the lights um trying to get you know I
mean otherwise going any blackout
curtains Etc and it's it's not
reasonable to then impose that I don't
think on the the the homes that are
nearby um I won't be supporting this
application whatsoever because I think
look how close I urge everyone to look
how close it is to people's houses if
you live in the at house and you've got
young children how would you feel about
trying to get your kids to bed um it's
not it's not okay really so I think that
the I mean even if everything was even
if they were great neighbors and and all
that the enforcement was because if
things change is going in into prce in
the planning department and you're going
to have a screening of that one would
argue why wasn't this done ages ago
quite frankly but I get that we are
where we are now and that's going to now
be brought in but I still think it's
acceptable for the Neighbors so I'll be
I'll be I'll be proposing actually and
see if anyone wants to to join me but
I'll be proposing that we um actually
refuse the application thank you thank
you councel
bar so I'd be um basically going with
the comments made by my colleague
councilor Thomas while I have all the
sympathies you know for the neighbors
but um I think it's reassuring that you
know the management plan makes it
compulsory to have you know necessary
and um you know safety measures in terms
of the lighting and making it hard you
know as the points were raised in
relation to um leaving the lights on or
too much life you know for the
Neighbors making it hard for the kids to
go B early but you know if the
management plan um is implemented the
way it should be I think that would be
enough for me to be satisfied and I'll
be happy to second the motion thank you
coun
Taylor yeah I what council of Minister
I'll be opposing this because i' this is
my wward and I've been there with
campaign and cening when it's been after
7 o' and it is noise and swearing so
this whole it closes itself that's not
true like I've been there when all you
hear is effing and the c word and it's
like I understand people have B when
playing football but it's like it's like
half s at night and it is so bright and
it's so loud and it's so noisy everyone
is parking all over the road it's like
if you're in a wheelchair or on a pram
or even if you're just a normal person
you're having to walk into the road
because people don't care like it's is
constant and I'm thinking if we allow
this even if it's just one hour one hour
is too much for lots of people and if
you're having a weekend you're trying to
sit in your garden all you hear is
people scream because we know what
people get like with football we know
what they get like with Sport and it's
just going to kick off because it is
black pool eliminations Cil says I've
seen it at nights when I've been when
I've G to the ball's head and they're
still on even though they're not
supposed to be it could be 10:00 and the
lights are on so this I've been for 5
months and it's it's a recurring issue
whereby people are still playing on the
fields way past when they should be at
night when I'm driven past at night so I
don't know what the school is talking
about but I would be opposing it because
it's a
[Music]
mess I will be supporting this
application
I think this is a a really good scheme
and it's an attempt to provide uh sports
facilities for our young people and
there is a shortage of sports facilities
in in Trafford and it is needed and yeah
I I have sympathy with the residents but
this is a facility for our children and
I think it it's really important that we
should actually be supported this and I
think um you know if they do have a a
proper management plan to make sure that
um the conditions that are set and I
think it's it's an extra hour um it's
8:00 I think that is reasonable um and I
think if if the you know if the plan is
monitored by our officers um then it
should work and uh I I you know I I
would move
coun
Thomas Swit your micophone that's it
that's okay coun yeah been moved anybody
else councelor
e thank
you if he's in seconded I don't know if
might officially yes but I will second
Council Minister his proposal to review
use this plan application I feel like
the management plan wouldn't hold
confidence that work going forward if
this was
um accepted um I think it's important to
for us as councilors for our local areas
to understand that the planning process
is quite matter of fact and it's very
easy to think I was only an extra hour
pars good for their children good to
sports but we represent our
residents and there's a huge amount of
representations against this
proposal
um we we really do need to think about
how we look after the resident wishes
and
concerns because for for the residents
there are this is their only way to
appeal and be listened to in this
process um I have full appreciation of
the concerns that have been raised from
the residents and um Council Serv his
comments so I'll be uh refusing as well
thank you thank you councelor thank you
counc somebody else Council
Hassan thank you
uh I will be supporting this application
and to be honest and very strongly uh it
is not all about the for the for the
school uh children it is all the the
community cross that area and for the
mental and social health and if we talk
about the parking issue and noise it is
always even in front of many many other
schools across the world across the
country so I don't think there's any any
strong uh points have been raised by my
colleague uh I would say yes it is a
good scheme and I will strongly
recommend and go ahead thank
you thank you Council coun
Jerome thanks chair um I find
myself sitting in the middle agreeing
with both sides there are strong
Arguments for the sporting side of it
and giving people access to you know
Leisure and exercise but I also take it
account the resident opinions and
councilor 's um objection as well and I
I think the AG aggravations there are
are real and genuine and extending it by
an hour does make a difference I think
in previous committees when I served
maybe two or three years ago we
sometimes granted permission like this
for a year um and then it allowed it to
come back after a year and then we could
see if that management plan had actually
worked and whether we could Grant it
from much you know for for indefinitely
so I just wanted if there was a
compromise here in that we could Grant
it for only a
year thank you Council jome anybody any
members wish to comment councel
Min just come back to that um Council
Jerome's um possible suggestion the
thing is to Grant it for a year you
you'd want all of the um conditions in
place
already to be able to try that out so
you'd need all the screening you'd need
all the things that are going to try and
limit the light and and lighting
everyone's Gardens up right and into
their Windows you need to do all that
first first and then try out a year and
see if and and actually proactively go
and speak to the resident to see do they
find it acceptable I think that's
probably the only way in which you could
do that I don't think that's something
that the council going to end up doing I
don't think anyone's going to go around
asking these people is it okay it's
going to be down to those that actually
complain and as we know not everybody
does complain but they will be
impacted so I'm just just as
thought actually sorry just like a you
know um I just I I think for me I have a
you I do generally when we've had
applications in the past when it's not
so close literally that close to
people's houses I go you know an extra
hour it's not that bad but look how
close it is right imagine living in
those houses and see and think what it'
be like life would be like for you right
and and then and then it actually put
yourself in those people's shoes and
then go no is that okay it's not is it
really right I mean my kids are not tiny
tiny now but they're still quite young
and I would find it okay so anyway but
thank
you counc Thomas thank you chair just
just to point out this might might
without the cows and without the LED
lights that been brought in as it says
in the report but with the cows this
might affect four
houses four probably won't affect the
extreme
ones to the E side and as light doesn't
Bend and come back on itself with the
cows it should have a very negative
effect on anybody's house we're talking
about getting health and well-being into
a community most of the community will
have access to use these this facility a
good facility as well and only till at
8:00 I've not heard from i' like to be
ConEd or given advice on this a genuine
planning reason for
refusing you
know I I can't see a PL reason to refuse
this I think he's an excellent one
there's car OD car parking spaces for
two pictures you can only have 11 aside
at maximum so I I just I just don't see
the objections at all I think health and
wellbeing of the youth and adults that
will get perhaps use this and there's a
piece literally on the road across
across the road from the school I played
on many years ago and I assure you if it
was effing and jeffing and use of fuy
language that was still going on on the
park opposite so again it's not really a
plan reason it still support it 100%
thank
CH thank you councelor
Thomas I'm G just let one more speak on
this I think we've discussed it at
length so coun
the only the only point I want to raise
mean it is only lighting issue which can
be mitigated that's it otherwise it is
perfectly find a wonderful proposal to
sport how we can mitigate the lights
that I mean that's
it
um I would say that the just to be clear
I know um it's been referenc but it is
just for Monday to Friday wouldn't be
additional at we weend the school are
also aware that is currently
unauthorized use of the pictures and
they are looking to address that and
through um additional CCTV so I am aware
that is an ongoing issue in regards to
the flood lights I think from what we
understand is that they weren't
previously regulated so what we're
looking to do now is through the
management plan have um kind of striped
control on the lights um so they would
um have a a switch off time
um to allow um you know not only
replaces but they to take the lighting
away from those pictures completely at 8
8m and I do fully appreciate what what
what has been said but we considering
that it would be one additional hour
Monday to Friday and in in conversation
with our colleagues in Environmental
Health in nuisance we do not feel that
there is a strong enough planning reason
to refuse it and we feel that the impact
could be mitigated through condition
if if members wanted the hour temporary
the temporary hour for a year it would
need to be clear that we have done this
elsewhere as the Drone is correct that
the impact that people are hearing is
just between seven and 8 so any existing
use up till 700 p.m. or is not in our
control so that when it if it came back
after a year that if people are still
unhappy and that they are clear that we
are looking at the the hour till 7 to8
but it is an option we have done it
recently I think on Bing um cricket and
Hockey Club so it has been done
elsewhere but um that is for members to
to look at thank you m milma um can I
just say I have to read this out to
members the council's Environmental
Protection Service has confirmed this is
on page 8 the council's Environmental
Protection Service confirmed that no
complaints have been received regarding
artificial lighting Ed for the mugg
pictures to which this application
relates so if if residents have got
issues and I don't doubt they have got
issues I think Council Minister alluded
to it but you need you you need to
complain and I have to say not just
complain to the local Council but to
complain to the council that's what our
council is there for that's what our
officers are there for you need to make
those issues known
um we've had a proposal that we go for a
temporary uh permission for this for one
year
um just bear with
you have we got I think councilor Jerome
well he he floated that idea would you
like to make that a proposal Council
Jerome yeah I would like to propose that
we we Grant the application for a year
and then we can review it again
and then we would review it after one
you would anybody like to Second councel
Taylor Sor I'll
second so that's been that's been moved
and seconded that we Grant this
application
for just tempor for one year councelor
minis um if we do that can we have all
the um all the things in place the
medication part in place so we can have
it as a real situation
rather than let them have it for a year
as it is currently without the shielding
without the screaming Etc with all the
screening and everything in place
already then one year rather than just
want to minimize misery
please okay I'm being vied legally when
it said refusal proposal first it was
moving second that refuse the
application so we need a reason for
refuser we have to take that motion
first from from what i' I've heard in
the room you you're saying that the
additional hour um would cause noise and
disturbance to the harm to residential
amenity so that's that's the gist yeah
okay you
yeah okay so it's moving secondly that
we refuse the application on for the
reasons that M nman has just outlined
all those in favor of refusing the
application please
show okay hands down and those against
refusing the
application okay thank you so the
application has not been refused so
we'll go for the temporary
granting unless anybody
else got any proposals both the
temporary uh permission all those in
favor of granting for a temporary period
of one year please
sh just hang on hands down please
Council prop you're looking
confused I am thank
you if the proposal to extend it for a
year Falls do we then go to the proposal
to accept it as is that's that's I don't
know which to vote for I want to vote
for
this and and so you're right Council
that's what we will do then we will go
for a full full proposal for permanent
use yeah okay so we'll start again all
those in favor granting a temporary
permission for one year subject to the
conditions we want them all in place and
we want our residents looking at our
conservative councilors to remind our
residents to
complain hope they haven't had any
complaints but you need
to um all those in favor of oneyear
granting please
show okay hands down those against a
onee
permission okay so it's been carried
we're going to Grant onee permission on
the
application we hope everybody's happy
[Music]
can we ask this to
come okay everybody the next one go to
is pry everybody every going to go to PR
number one prery Avenue and that's 100
page 116 of your application Pack Mr da
give us an introduction to this one Mr
da thank
you
and this application relates to a
two-story semi- attached property on the
Eastern side of prur
Avenue
um so yeah I just put the site p on the
screen
um so the property is on the Eastern
side of prer Avenue at Junction with
Wellington Road in the residential area
Al close to the navigation Road M
station
Planning Commission is sought for the
erection of a part symol part two story
side and their extansion the alterations
also include the conversion of the
garage into habital accommodation
although it recognized that this element
could be carried out without the need
for planning
permission the extension would provide a
bedroom and on suite and an open plan
kitchen and Lounge area at ground floor
level and a fifth bedroom at first floor
level to the rear of the
GL the application is reported to
committee because 13 object have been
received contrary to the officer
recommendation um just
quickly sorry just going through the
slides yeah I'm just to get
back
okay so the elevations of the um
proposal you can see there it's
basically a single story wraparound
extension wrapping around the side and
rear of the property with the F small
first floor element at the
rear um the site plan um showing two
parking spaces on the Frontage
um site layout site location plan um
that's looking across um at the site
from along presy Avenue um viewing the
site from the Northeast along Wellington
Road
um again viewing the site across the
junction of warington Road in pres
Avenue and that's the photograph of the
application property on the right hand
side and number three press having you
the joining property at the rear
um the key issues for consideration in
the application of the proposals design
impact on residential immunity and
highways
par there have been significant
amendments to the orig sign PLS
including the removal of the first four
side elements and the reduction in the
width of the single story side
extension officers consider the proposal
as amended would not have any unaccept
for impact on the cage of the street
scene the rear projection of 3 met is
compliant with fb4 gu
and the proposal is considered to be
acceptable in terms of its impact upon
the residential community of neighboring
properties The Proposal would also be
acceptable in terms of parking
impacts the application will therefore
comply with policy L 7 of the core
strategy and policies in the mpf and
it's recommended for approval subject to
conditions thank you Mr day we got a
statement from Brian and Susan Ford
their are Ang
yeah going to read that thank you
m thank you
chair i' request the following statement
be read out at committee on our behalf
thank you for the opportunity to address
the committee whilst we welcome some of
the adjustments made to the proposal our
previous objections are still largely
relevant we wish to address the mo the
most important issues to us of main
concern is the loss of Lights to the
rear of our house the existing window to
our rear elevation are still not
shown on the proposals the windows are
only 150 mm from the boundary of our
property new extension will therefore be
300 mm from the proposed extension at
right angles to these windows the first
the proposals show a 45° angle on the pl
while property however this is emitted
on the ground floor as the angle would
be some
85° there are very mature trees
approximately 25 foot from the rear of
the house which are approximately 80
feet high making the rear of our
property already dark the proximity of
The Proposal will make this situation
unbearable indeed paragraph
2.16 and 2.17 of your adopted policy SPD
4 state that positioning and extension
too close to neighboring property
boundaries can result in an
uncomfortable sense of enclosure to the
neighboring property an extension that
would overshadow your neighbor to an
unreasonable extent would not be
considered acceptable in our opinion
this is undoubtedly the case and
destroys our right to light and quality
of life thank you for listening to our
concerns Brian and Susan for three press
Avenue thank you thank you Miss L any
members wishing to
speak
Thomas thank you sure
um can't really say anything wrong with
the application I think it's a sensible
use of the space in the W around if I
had any
issue with it I think with the first the
first floor
extension second floor extension deping
looked it is a little bit strange to me
but from off the site no one notice it
doesn't look out of place in terms of um
symmetry on the road there are many
different styles of housing on the road
that doesn't can't reply that
um other than that I can find no reason
to to to object to it you could say that
the number three's extension has a
similar impact in terms of loss of light
to the the ground floor window um so I'm
quite happy to propose that we accept
this uh to gr next
the off
recommendation thank you councelor
Thomas councel Hassan yes I
second
microphone apology uh thank you sh I I
second to my my colleague
cons and
fly support the recommendation of the
officers there's no problem at all to
support this ucation my thank you thank
you anybody else wish to come in Council
jome thank you chair I I do sympathize
for the the residents at at number three
I mean um this wraparound um extension
does kind of maximize what they can do
with the plot um and the first floor
extension will have some overlooking
nature to it but um I think when you get
down to this application there aren't
any really any planning reasons to
refuse it and it is policy compant um I
think the residents do mention some of
the issues around the highway but um
again I don't think the application can
be responsible for for any of those and
I'm not sure any will will occur because
of this um extension
so I I I find myself supporting this
application and supporting officer
recommendations thanks chair thank you
councelor Jerome councelor
Min my only the issues really is the um
the second the next the first floor if
you will and the back but how close does
it just wanted to check how close does
it go to the
neighboring um there a question I know
the first will wrap wrap around how how
close does the first W bit go
to to the um party war will the um I
think that that's what the statement is
about the resident at number three but
um paragraph 10 page 121 um it gives
gives us those sizes and it says it's
it's with within ourd for within our
guidelines and indeed it just suggest it
could it could be made bigger actually
okay um the single story could be could
be
bigger sorry so yeah the single story
extension could could be higher and
still be built on development with the
same
projection any other the members wishing
to
comment
no okay it's been propos has it been
proposed it's been proposed by councelor
Thomson seconded by councel Hassan yes
that we Grant this application all those
in favor of granting please
show
thank youbody the application has been
granted and we'll go to page 126 that's
309 head Avenue and Mr D
Mr
de yeah thank you chair
um so this application also ra to a
two-story 70 touch delling house located
at the southern end of mad Avenue res
Fon um planning commiss sought for the
demolition of the existing side garage
and the erection of a two-story side
extension additional floor space for the
existing kitchen and create an
additional bedroom and on Suite bathroom
at first floor level the application is
reported to committee because six
objections have been received cont to
the officer
recommendation um again
just quickly running through the slides
um there you can see the front elevation
of the property and the joining property
um that's the side elevation of the
adjacent property number 28 M head
Avenue um
the location
plan and the site plan showing the
extension in in Hatch hatching um at the
side of the property um existing
elevations and the proposed elevations
shown the two story side
extension lay
P um the key issues consideration theal
design impact on residential imunity and
highways and parking impacts officers
consider that theal would not have any
unacceptable impact on the immunity of
the occupi of neighboring dwellings The
Proposal is also considered to be
acceptable in terms of design and visual
immunity and would not have any
acceptable parking this therefore
consider the proposal is in accordance
with policy all seven of the core
strategy and policies in the mpf and
Asser the application is recommended for
approval subject conditions thank you
chair
thank you Mr day do we have Mr
oiv to take a seat and switch this
microphone off you've got three minutes
thank you very much chair never thought
i' be back in this
room I have a thought I'd be back in
this room 35 years ago since I worked at
traford I've set out a letter that I
originally set out on the 24th of July
to abouts I emailed all members
yesterday spent sorry I spent 38 years
England is Scotland and
Wales uh in planning I'm a member of the
RO time plan Institute and I have to pay
M own
fees uh everything ultimately comes to
an end we should not ever forget that I
spent a lifetime working with members
working with residents and sometimes the
observations are
misplaced I've come through my own
valtion from West Coke where I
live if I had if I had a hot dinner for
every application I've dealt with I
would be morbidly obese if you ask me
how many planning applications I've
submitted in my life one I have a house
on 6 AC in my C which I design myself
not a single objection lesss of support
these days of support tend to be framed
because they're few and far between I
see on your agenda you have up to 40
pages in uh of reports detering Planet
applications you look at what I've
designed you could not you could not sub
submit anything more innocuous for the
side extension it's is
25.6 square meters internally it's not
even the volume of the space in front of
us it's
4.65 it's 3.3 MERS wide it doesn't
affect any amenity some of the issues of
objections and I noticed that uh no
one's here today not understanding the
fact that I've come 410 miles and some
people have not come 4.1 miles according
to Mr gole it complies with the spirit
of your guidelines it does not affect
the humanity of any adoran property when
I read the issue of uh parking issues
I'm somewhat surprised that the
residents haven't actually packed out
the CAC because what actually happens
there the CAC is so substandard that you
can't park anywhere unless you park on
the pavement which there's a gray area
on that unless you're blocking someone's
driveway that doesn't happen you don't
park in front of someone's driveway when
you look at the other
objections they've thrown in know them
stand up your officers have done a
professional assessment please respect
that professional assessment they
conclud clude that he's an appropriate
form of development I'm at the end of my
career uh I will be coming back I will
be coming back because my son's come
back he works he's now a chartered
accountant uh he works for one of the
big four I can't I can't rattle around
in a big house and six acres of land my
accent hasn't changed you'll hear it I
find it sad I know what discrimination
is I find it sad when people people are
ethnocentric and refer to uh developers
from another country this is part of my
country I know F the back of my hand and
as I said this is only the second
application tomorrow morning I'll be at
ringway that's what we used to call it
I'll be dealing with applications in
West C and I'll be dealing with that
application exactly like you dealt with
the first application on was 22 thank
you very much for your time thank you Mr
to return to you see please thank
you any members wishing to speak counc
Thomas thank
you thank you chair um for those of us
that don't know mood Avenue manood
Avenue is a bu is a is a very small qu
at this part of it that is full of
Bungalows and a couple of sort of s and
one with a small three bedroomies and
maybe a couple more further down the
road this would be very overbearing you
will not in any way uh Adorn Street scen
in in a an advantageous manner it's very
close to a bundo next door um I'm not
overly concerned about the effect on the
residents of BU Avenue but in terms of
keeping and remaining the the the garden
Frontage the issue of parking
is um very real we're going to have a
four bedroom property with possibly one
maybe two uh car parking spaces on a
cack on a turning cical in a cack um the
massing would that size of house would
be totally our car of the Min Avenue
total I'm afraid that I'm going to have
to go against the officer recommendation
and
obviously committee propos we reject
this
application thank you counc m refus
thank you Council
proor sorry Simon I like
this it's not a huge extension it's got
plenty of garden around it so there's no
loss of imunity to the Garden from
looking at the drawing on screen the
extension is going to be no nearer
the house to the left of it and top than
the current corner of the house I think
it's good design and I move to
accept thank you councel prop any
councel
Barber I don't see any um issues when it
comes to planning all the um you know
requirements have been met and I'm happy
to chose a
second anybody else like to comment
um I'll can I just say I've been looking
at this through the week and I've been
badgering Steven day about the effects
on number 28 I couldn't see any issues
with um the properties at the rear and
uh but I've been badgering now while we
and there are no planning reasons to
turn this application I have to disagree
with you Council I think it's a very
good application I agree with Mr
O and I I like it Council said it
doesn't say c space it's no nearer to
the boundaries in the house that's there
at the moment so I'll be supporting it
there's no other speakers will go to
AO all those in favor of granting this
application please
show Q hands down those again just the
one coun Thomas thank you that
application been granted thank you
Mr we go to our final application this
evening oh sorry getting excited to go
um page page 88 on your P that's
Avenue thank you chair um so this
application relates to a semach property
on the North side on Sil Avenue in
Temple the application proposes a uh
Brown and two story sing r exension and
front porch and we have received a
couple of objections from the neighbors
either side um concerns about ameni
specifically LW Supply overshadowing and
also concern about the longevity of
construction and councilor FR has called
it in support of those um neighbors so
the this is just some photographs of um
the application property and the
neighboring property which does have the
non- adjoining property 179 does have
habitable room windows on the side
elevation
um whilst offices um being mindful of
those objections we've looked at the
orientation of the site and because um
it kind of the rear py faces North and
what we've done is secured a change to
the front so the the two-story side
extansion would be set back from the
front at first floor by 2.5 MERS and to
maximize direct sunlight so as the sun
comes around this would um maximize
direct sunlight to the light to sry to
the windows on the side elevation of
this property um the application is
complying with sd4 and we consider it
also complies with policy L7 of the core
strategy and following the Amendments we
are now happy to recommend approval
subject to the conditions in your report
thank you chair thank you Mr n there's
no speakers to this item uh
[Music]
Min thank you chair so whilst it's has
been there's lots of been changes being
made which are positive far better I
think than how it would have possibly
started out as um I still feel like it's
a bit much for the Neighbors
um but I I I acknowledge it's a hell of
a lot
better um than what could have happened
I could could have been here would have
been here had it not got amended so um
applaud the C the officers on on there
trying to get get it scal back to
improve the situation for for Neighbors
um I do feel like it's a little bit too
much though um in terms of the scale
nothing but um I appreciate everything
you've done thank
you thank you councelor Min councelor
Thomas thank you chair um oos to accept
this recommendation there are houses not
100 yards of the street I think there's
three in a row with similar side
extensions to wounds and second
floor uh extensions I can see no reason
for for not i' have been happy with it
if it had come to the front rather than
what it is now but if the neighbors are
more happier with the the setb then it's
better for communities but Happ poose
thank you thank you councel Thomas
councel bar thank you chair um on
planning grounds and you know guance in
the framework complies with it and I'm
happy to
Second thank you anybody else wish to
comment uh councelor Thomas has moved
that we Grant the application councel
bar second in the application nobody
else wants to speak all those in favor
Grant this application please show
hands down those against Min thank
you and now we're going to go to the
last application which is at two George
Street that's 137 on your application
pack and M lo
lo thank you chair and this application
relates to uh section 73 for minor
material amendment to development that's
previously been approved moved at two
George Street which is the former Rens
in
ALR um work has significantly progressed
on the original planning application
which sought to refurbish and extend the
existing um reckons building for use as
offices and Commercial uses and as I say
this application proposes a minor
material amendment to that original
commission and allow us for some
internal changes to the FL layout and
mainly to increase the flexibility of
the uses permitted for each of the four
ground FL units and this has been
proposed to reflect the T tendency
interest the applicant has received no
external changes to the building are
proposed and the new classes to be and
no new classes are to be introduced it
will just allow that flexibility three
units will have a flexible use for
retail office and cafe and one unit will
have a flexible use for retail office
and restaurant and Cafe overall these
changes would would not fundamentally
alter the development as previously
approved and would not result in any
additional adverse impacts to the Town
Center or residential ameni subject to
the conditions as detailed in the report
the application is therefore recommended
for approval subject to the conditions
thank you
chair this Lo any members wishing to
comment counc Thomas thank you thank you
chair I was on the committee when this
came last time we were all extremely
excited about it I think it's only going
to enhance the success that's going to
be around altering them and residents Al
should be very excited because they will
draw people in I recommend that we
accept and
Grant thank you I'll take that you
moving it councel Thomas councel
Barber sorry I'm happy to Second
Thomas's
motion thank you anybody else wish to
comment it's just a change of use make
those units more flexible no change to
the building um okay it's been moving
second in all those in favor gr
application please show that's
unanimous and I think that concludes our
meeting thank you everybody for
attendance